quand j'ai commencé très jeune a 8 ans
quelque chose va approcher la chez maguy
marin figures de la danse contemporaine
se confie elle est l'invitée d'honneur
de la conversation publique qui s'est
tenue à la bibliothèque de l'ue vs qu un
retour sur son parcours ses inspirations
et ses créations sam informe aussi de
comment les gens voient la danse ou
comment les gens voient le travail sa
main forme ça me donne des informations
sur la façon dont les gens perçoivent
les choses quoi mais ça m'intéresse
je n'accepte plein des conversations
publiques et surtout quand il s'agit
d'étudiants toujours des moments que
j'aime beaucoup en fait ces rencontres
avec des jeunes gens ces jeunes sont au
nombre de six ils font partie d'un
collectif tête à tête qui veut
promouvoir le spectacle vivant pour les
étudiants
on se rend compte que la dans les salles
de spectacle c'est toujours le même
public les habitués et en fait mine de
rien le spectacle vivant la culture ça
amène
du lien social un aspect de vie qu'on
n'a pas forcément la danse contemporaine
où on peut croire que c'est assez
élitiste en fait sauf que maguy marin
elle absolument pas vous l'avait violée
hyper généreusement ses dents serrées
bruce et est allée elle dénonce en fait
énormément et c'est ça qui nous
intéressait cette conversation publique
était leur premier grand rendez vous une
conversation possible grâce au théâtre
national de saint quentin en yvelines